le pire est passé à manaus la vie
normale a presque repris même si les
écoles sont encore fermées il n'y a pas
plus de dix décès par jour de l'aco vide
les habitants sont soulagés damas
confortable dif et aoudia dire manaus et
une grosse agglomération 3 millions
d'habitants avec des industries
multinationales en zone franche
mais en fait c'est une île une enclave
isolée par les rio negro et salles
immenses affluent de l'amazone à côté et
de l'autre par l'immense forêt vierge
manaus et exactement au centre de
l'amazonie on y accède presque
uniquement en bateau et en avion c'est
comme ça claque au vide est arrivé avec
deux mois de retard dans un milieu aussi
fermé la première vague a fait des
ravages des adresses os akina stade
trois habitants sur quatre ici
connaissent quelqu'un qui en est mort
mais qu'on ne parle pas à marcelo du
variant de manaus où d'amazonie c'est le
variant brésilien point pourtant il est
né ici
ici il a pris son autonomie il a muté
dans ce bouillon de culture on a
découvert elle varie un ici à manaus est
possible que ça c'est une évolution du
virus
ici on avait beaucoup de personnes
infectées
alors ça pourrait faciliter le
développement de nouvelles variantes le
docteur markus lacerda spécialiste de
médecine tropicale de l'institut fédéral
oswald crous l'a vu venir mais personne
n'a voulu croire à la deuxième vague
manaus n'était pas préparé des premiers
symptômes inquiétants se manifeste à
noël alors c'est l'enfer mais en mai
l'an fer pur que le premier pire on a vu
beaucoup de personnes qui sont morts
chez eux
lots à l'hôpital il n'a pas d'oxygène
alors c'est cette dramatique pendant
deux trois semaines on ne peut faire
rien il n'a pas de lier à l'hôpital mais
on avait
dans une seule fois 170 personnes au
cimetière de man ans
un jour un seul jour encore plus
dramatique le sort des communautés
éloignées indigènes pour la plupart
difficiles à rejoindre par bateau pour
des soins où la vaccination
une deuxième vague d'un variant beaucoup
plus mortel même chez des plus jeunes
et là encore une fois personne n'a
compris ce qui allait se passer ensuite
encore une fois le brésil n'était pas
prêt manaus en amazonie est un grand
laboratoire
je crois qu'aujourd'hui maintenant
hausse c'est la ville où faire la
surveillance en amérique latine de sac
va passer au futur du brésilien au futur
de l'amérique latine
les vaccins sont efficaces raison ne
sais pas pour combien de temps alors
qu'on essaie de prévoir la suite le
docteur lacerda surveille 5000 personnes
vaccinées pour voir la durée de leurs
anticorps sur 12 mois sur n'a une
nouvelle variante pole dance 2 mois
suivante
l'idée c'est de faire la recherche et de
les trouver
avant que cette variante soit trouvée au
japon par exemple dans un autre pays
la deuxième vague est passé ici en
amazonie mais pas encore dans le reste
du brésil
maintenant tout le monde se demande s'il
y aura une troisième vague et si elle
sera provoqué une nouvelle fois par un
nouveau variant tout est possible et si
cela devait arriver il est probable que
ça commence ici dans la région de manaus
sauf si la vaccination parvient à
l'empêcher jean michel leprince sera du
canada manaus